Bernie Sanders says that the failure of
Silicon Valley Bank is not because of
woke the way Republicans have been
claiming but it is at least partially
because of Donald Trump and Bernie
Sanders is completely correct in 2018
Donald Trump on camera multiple times
bragged about eliminating restrictions
on so-called Community Banks put in
place by Dodd-Frank this is partially to
blame for the under regulation of banks
like svb allowing them or arguably even
encouraging them to take on more risk
even in a sort of declining Tech
environment that has been the case for
the last six to nine months and if any
individuals outside of the bank are to
blame for what happened Trump is well
more to blame than anybody that would
fall under the umbrella of woke give me
a break